I hate that I have to do this next story
but I have to do it
because there's so much riding on this
next election Joe Rogan recently said
very nice things about Bernie Sanders
and that he'd likely vote for Bernie
Sanders some people are calling it an
endorsement others are not whether it is
or isn't an endorsement or just praise a
portion of the left has gone absolutely
crazy in the really toxic
self-destructive circular firing squad
way that I have been begging and
pleading the left not to do since day
one of the 2020 Democratic race now it's
important to understand there are two
sides to this there are people who are
sort of in the Bernie camp who are
furious about Bernie accepting /not
rejecting the nice words from Joe Rogan
there are also centrist opportunists who
are using this to fuel unrest within the
left and I'm going to talk about both of
them but first let's look at a sort of
condensed version of what Joe Rogan said
this was assembled by the Bernie Sanders
campaign this is part of the anger that
Bernie would use what Joe Rogan said and
use it as campaign video as campaign
material let's take a look at it who you
gonna vote for in the primary I think I
think I'll probably vote for Bernie him
as a human being when I was hanging out
with him yeah I believe in him I like
him I like him a lot what Bernie stands
for is a guy who look you could you
could dig up dirt on every single human
being that's ever existed if you catch
them in their worst moment and you
magnify those moments and you cut out
everything else and you only display
those display those worst moments that
said you can't find very many with
Bernie he's been insanely consistent his
entire life he's basically been saying
the same thing and for the same thing
his whole life and that in and of itself
is a very powerful structure to operate
from and there are people on the Left
including Bernie supporters who were
saying this is disgusting Joe Rogan is
horrible
he's transphobic he's sexist he's
homophobic he's racist misogynistic
throwing everything out there and Bernie
should
reject the endorsement if it was even an
endorsement again joe says he's going to
vote for Bernie not everybody should
vote for Bernie he's not saying I'm
endorsing Bernie he's saying I think
I'll probably vote Bernie that doesn't
even really matter here what are we
doing what why are we this stupid there
are two camps here okay there are the
people who genuinely support the Bernie
politics and are furious about Joe Rogan
because they don't like Joe Rogan they
don't want Joe Rogan's help in getting
Bernie elected then there are people who
don't actually support Bernie Sanders
and they're fabricating the anger to try
to hurt Bernie concern trolling oh if
someone as transphobic and sexist as Joe
Rogan is supporting Bernie that should
really get us to be concerned about
Bernie Sanders right those types of
people I want to focus on the people
actually mad at Bernie for embracing
rather than rejecting the endorsement
first Joe Rogan is one of the biggest
podcasts in the world you combine the
YouTube audience about seven and a
quarter million subscribers on one
channel about three and a half million
on the other channel that's ten million
YouTube subscribers you combine that
with one of the largest audio podcasts
in the world Joe Rogan is saying to his
audience especially by the way if you
believe Joe Rogan's audience is to the
right of Bernie Sanders and to your
right like if you're a leftist then you
see Joe and his audience as to your
right Joe Rogan is saying to his
audience hey I'm probably voting for
Bernie Sanders arguably the leftmost
person here wouldn't you be happy about
that as a leftist Joe Rogan could
single-handedly be handing primary wins
to Bernie Sanders with his endorsement
or praise of Bernie in some of these
states where it's Bernie Biden by a few
points within the margin of error and
they're both gonna end up with a similar
number of Delegates because of
proportional apportionment why wouldn't
you want Joe Rogan to possibly flip
states in Bernie's favor that's how big
an influential Joe Rogan's platform is
so if you like Bernie and you want
Bernie to win and you're publicly
denouncing Joe Rogan and saying you
don't want the endorsement what's wrong
with you Joe actually makes the argument
in analyzing Bernie that we should make
about Joe Rogan
if you look at what is it ten years or
more of Joe Rogan doing this type of
media I know he's been around longer but
were you're kind of hearing Joe Rogan's
thoughts you can compile stuff that most
progressives wouldn't be comfortable
with in terms of comments about women
trans people others I've always seen Joe
Rogan be willing to talk about the stuff
he had me on his program and I told him
when I thought he was doing things on
his show that weren't necessarily useful
in terms of how he platform's her
interviews and we just had a
conversation and it was perfectly fine
but so then what like if Bernie wins the
nomination without rejecting Joe's
endorsement and eventually Bernie as
president you're gonna be upset because
it happened with the help of Joe Rogan
if Joe Rogan convinces people in his
audience imagine that there's a whole
bunch of transphobes
in Joe Rogan's audience that hear Joe
say I think I'm voting Bernie and they
say you know what I'm also gonna vote
for Bernie okay hopefully after voting
for Bernie their views on transgender
people would be revised in the direction
that we would agree with like what's the
downside to that why are you mad this is
the height of missing the forest for the
trees
and unfortunately some major groups are
making this worse and this is an example
now of the other group the left-wing
group moveon.org which some call a
progressive group some call a centrist
establishment Democratic group they are
now calling for Bernie to renounce the
so-called endorsement of Joe Rogan where
they tweeted quote it's one thing for
Joe Rogan to endorse a candidate it's
another for Bernie Sanders campaign to
produce a video bolstering the
endorsement of someone known for
promoting transphobia homophobia
Islamophobia racism and misogyny we urge
senator Sanders and his campaign to
apologize and stop elevating this
endorsement we stand in solidarity with
folks hurt by this this is the exact
self destructive nonsense that will lead
to four more years of Donald Trump and
again a lot of these concerns are not
genuine concerns people aren't genuinely
concerned they're using this to try to
hurt Bernie people who support Biden or
Buddha jej or war you know establishment
candidates or simply other candidates
they are dishonestly and in bad faith
pretending like this is a huge thing
that upsets them about Bernie in order
to just
foment anger and division at Bernie they
just don't want Bernie Sanders to win I
don't know that I have much more to say
to them other than it's working because
they are firing up actual Bernie
supporters and getting them to say
things that make no sense this is the
worst of the left okay being angry about
praise from someone with one of the
largest platforms in favor of your
candidate and it's absolutely and
totally horrible now let's do the full
thing though let's deal with the things
Joe Rogan has said um there are clips
that have been circulating of Joe Rogan
saying things that sound to be racist
years ago or Joe Rogan having you know
insensitive or unenlightened takes on
trans issues okay so what do we gain by
attacking Bernie over this clearly Rogan
agrees with Bernie on enough that he
says I'm probably voting for him
shouldn't we say Joe that's great
we love that you recognize that your
values and Bernie's are aligned on a lot
of issues it's good for the country come
on over and by the way hopefully as you
get into this and follow Bernie's
campaign your views will evolve where we
don't agree isn't that the actual
progressive and smart and logical thing
and correct thing to do this slice of
the left is not something that I'm a
part of it's small but it's loud and we
need to make sure that they don't join
forces unwittingly with the astroturf
furs who are actually doing this to
support centrist candidates and hurt
Bernie because this will all damage our
opportunity to defeat Donald Trump in
November let's not fall for it and I
hope people in my audience will join me
in not participating in it next Sunday
is my birthday we have a huge membership
special plan for my birthday actually
this this membership special is so
outrageous the the age V of New York
said David I'm worried that this might
be too good of a deal we may have to
indict in New York State if you run this
deal and I said you know what I don't
care we're giving the deal on my
birthday if you want to be notified
about this membership special on my
birthday
just get on our newsletter okay go to
david pakman.com there's a spot in the
upper right of the website to type in
your email
on february 2nd you'll be notified about
this special and it'll be a beautiful
thing one of our sponsors is privacy
calm they're giving you $5.00 when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy calm slash Pakman
I've been using privacy for a little
over a year now you've heard me talk
about it before it's a lifesaver and
here's how it works takes just a couple
of minutes to set up anytime you buy
something online or on the phone instead
of actually using your real credit card
number the privacy app and the browser
plugin let you give each company a
randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even autofill the card number with one
click and the payment is taken out of
your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to twelve of these virtual
credit cards a month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this it means you're not going to
be charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a $10 a month plan that gives you
one percent cashback and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a $25 a
month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get $5 to spend when you
sign up at privacy calm / Pakman